the protest started peacefully
with demonstrators chanting
pro-democracy songs
there was heavy police presence some
officers even moving alongside the small
crowd
until the first cordon was breached
then the security forces lobbed rounds
of tear gas at the protesters
the crowd including dozens of
journalists had to run
to find safety police then fired
gunshots
into the air bengal
who participated in the first june 12
movement 28 years ago
says the ideals they fought for have
been destroyed
by the political class that's why
they're back on the streets
nigerians saw it a duty to themselves
and to their generation yes
to begin to come out a mass you're like
we came out to the decade
that started with june 12 1993 to come
out time to begin to say no to this
nonsense that is going on
the june 12 movement was born after the
annulment of an election in 1993
arguably the freest in nigeria's history
the winner of that vote was later
arrested by the military
and died in detention what followed were
protests
and violence that grouped the nation
forcing the military
to organize another transfer of power to
civilians
six years later that transition to
civilian power
is marked here every year as democracy
day
but some activists who took part in last
year's anti-police brutality protest
that turned violent at times stayed away
this year
saying street protests like this can
easily be hijacked by opportunists
nigeria is sitting on the keg of
gunpowder and anything
can we can make it explode so i am not
on the street because i feel that
as a nigerian one my loyalties with my
country
protests were also reported in other
cities including the capital abuja
where pro and anti-government protesters
clashed
ahead of the protest security forces
have been deployed in large numbers here
in lagos
and across nigeria the protests are
coming at a time
when nigerians are angry at politicians
for failing
to rein in widespread violence
corruption inflation
and poverty worried about the repeat of
the anti-police brutality protest last
year that resulted in widespread looting
in arson
many businesses in lagos remained closed
on saturday
earlier in a nationwide broadcast to
mark the day president muhammad buhari
acknowledged existing challenges facing
nigeria
he assured the public the nation's
democracy will continue to evolve
until such challenges are met but
millions of citizens
burdened by inflation economic
stagnation
and violence say the change must happen
now ahamad idris al jazeera
lagos nigeria